riley how are you today it's i feel like
i'm in the presence of just
like barbra streisand i adore you riley
japanese greatness right
right there that's right are you
japanese riley i am
yeah yeah yeah how's church it's
it's pretty great great i love that for
you you're a man of god
i'm a woman of the lord so that's why he
just opened the door earlier tonight we
just connected i felt the holy spirit
i could see that i felt it yeah and
riley last year got his first
kiss actually oh hell yeah hell yeah how
was it tongue
yeah oh yeah it was pretty great yes
yes yes cleaning the palette baby with
that freaking little ginger snap there
you go
now riley i'm a great matchmaker that's
just like one of my talents so if you
if you tell me like what you like i mean
you can be very specific with it if
you're like
i want her to have green eyes and you
know be into anime
and you know love chipotle like i will
find her so don't ever
you feel like you can ask me i will find
doctor you saw us they call him dr suss
oh hell yeah yeah we're talking about
green green eyes and breasts what uh
what do you like riley honestly if you
are looking for a woman i think
heather's very serious about that damn
that she would consider helping you out
brother
um yeah i mean i'm uh i'm i'm more of
the uh
i don't i don't i'm i'm honestly open to
anything not not anything anything but
like
um i mean like give us one
one detail yeah give us a neat deal like
you talking so are we talking five to
six feet what are we talking about yeah
cool um honestly as tall as you want
um like six four i mean you know do you
want to be cuddled at night like
you got just give me specifics how do
you want to feel about a date okay i
like being cuddled
okay great all right so a larger woman
okay larger woman
fantastic um i mean i'd like to cuddle
her as well
so maybe she has one short leg one long
leg
it huh yeah exactly um yeah
um let's see what's fantastic that's all
i need
right there i got it and it's about what
you get out of them
it's uh yeah yeah you know it's a
waiting game
give me a block it's a game show you say
give me a blonde give me a blonde oh
okay
okay there we go see i like that and
it's okay i think men now feel
intimidated like they can't say what
they want
but just be honest about it like i have
a very specific i want a woman
yeah i want a woman that's fine i want
somebody with a vagina
you know yeah i prefer a good attitude
and that we can find that there's plenty
of women out there with vaginas and good
attitudes now riley because we haven't
even really gotten into this raleigh and
i know have you been uh
since the kiss have you been doing any
more dating or is it
uh not yet no okay um attitude though
not yet
yeah not not yet but very optimistic you
gotta speak it into existence
exactly you know put it on the vision
board i used to think that was such
right and then i got high one like new
year's day and i made a vision board and
all this came true i was like
god damn okay so i think if you speak it
out into the universe you're just like i
want a blonde woman
who i can cuddle or maybe she cuddles me
you you'll see what happens
wow yeah you got it riley i mean look i
really believe and
is atlanta too far for you for a woman
not riley do you have a mileage uh do
you have a
a distance no atlanta how far is that
land in farts
not far at all 34-minute flight
four-hour drive i got you
not that but i got women all over like i
i have a posse of beautiful women in
nashville
yeah i got you okay i don't want to end
up in any sort of because
legally it's going to come back onto me
okay sorry
you know i know you love too i can find
you yeah how old are you riley i need to
make sure you're legal i'm i'm 22.
22 great great great yeah going on 23. i
love yeah yeah
that's when somebody's young they also
tell you how old they're about to be
next in 18 weeks
i'll be 23. yeah yeah yeah hey thanks
for letting me sweat on your couch this
is a real
magical afternoon yeah we're going to
auction off that that cushion actually
yeah let's get weird with it oh you're
sad lonely male followers
raleigh's probably going to keep that in
fact it'll smell like testosterone
riley ooh really i actually feel like
there's been a little sexual energy
between us
i really do i do i mean do you feel that
way oh yeah
okay good good riley is i mean all he
has a sexual energy
honestly radiates it radiates sexual
energy and i don't think you're living
your truth so i think
i'm gonna get you with a broad shoulder
then ankled
just big titty blonde girl who loves the
lord
you know she's in the youth about no not
youth sorry god no
no she's a youth group leader but she is
an adult
look let's be honest at some churches
she could be as long as she's kind of
like
uh as long as she's a pastor in training
a pit or whatever
that's her injury yeah whatever it is
you know
but i see it and i i just asked one
thing if i
find you your wife can i please
officiate the wedding sure
hell yeah okay great i love it look
who knows what can happen magic it could
be how magic starts
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one
you